au quai des orfèvres donc se trouve
antoine lopez toujours interrogé encore
ce soir mais s'ouvre et nous allons
faire tout le récit de cette histoire
revenons donc à vendredi 29 octobre
ce jour là le leader marocain
d'opposition mehdi ben barka a rendez
vous avec un étudiant marocain résidant
à paris tu as mis à zemmouri avec lui il
va se rendre à saint germain des prés où
il a rendez vous avec le cinéaste
georges franju à saint germain des prés
les deux hommes van den broeck store
consomme quelques instants puis ça et il
est 12h15 les hommes sortent trois
hommes sautent sur matt barr qu'à le
mettre dans une voiture et se sauve par
la rue de rennes on apprendra plus rien
après on apprendra que dimanche cet
enlèvement car l'étudiant s'est enfui à
flot mais il a parlé quand même les
policiers commencent à chercher et
mercredi finalement tout se découvre
tami a souri à parler les policiers
opèrent dans la région de corbeil tout
un certain nombre de perquisitions et de
recherche à fontenay le vicomte ils
perquisitionnent dans la maison d'un
certain bouche sèche ancien lieutenant
de pierrot le fou résidant actuellement
à casablanca
derrière ces maisons et dans la même
région ils fouillent les marées les
marécages et la rivière l'essonne ils
vont peut-être essayer de chercher un
corps de toute façon ils ne trouveront
rien et enfin une dernière une troisième
deuxième perquisition à ormoy dans la
villa de antoine lopez inspecteurs des
ventes à l'aérodrome d'orly ancien
résidant au maroc dans cette ville là
qu'ils ont fouillé pendant plusieurs
heures on ne sait pas ce qu'ils ont
trouvé toujours est il qu'au même moment
à orly sur son lieu de travail antoine
lopez et arrête
autres renseignements qui nous vient
aussi d'orly un message adressé le 23
octobre par téléphone à l'aérodrome
d'orly destiné à monsieur ben barka a
été inscrit c'est une hôtesse qui l'a
reçue par téléphone qu'il a inscrits
dans la case habituelle des télégrammes
mais ce message ne parviendra jamais à
monsieur ben barka la police bien sûr la
saisie c'est peut-être une nouvelle
source
celui qui a porté plaine c'est le frère
de monsieur ben barka monsieur abdel
kader ben barka que pense-t-il de toute
cette affaire c'est ce que nous allons
lui demander
je crois qu'il s'agit d'un enlèvement
car ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
a essayé d'enlever mon frère on a essayé
maintes fois en suisse et plus
précisément à genève
on a même essayé d'associer mais je
crois ceci au maroc où
ils ont été suivis par une voiture
police spéciale
sa voiture a été
obligé de
vous jeter dans
heureusement oui avec trois mois dans le
clac puisqu'il avait été touché à la
colonne vertébrale alors ceci vous mêmes
bien sûr formuler des hypothèses qui a
pu en leur sein vous savez moi je
soupçonne tout le monde je crois qu'on a
mis un peu de temps avant de boucler les
frontières ici en france et je ne serais
pas étonné que mon frère soit déjà au
maroc oui car les frontières n'ont pas
été bouclée instantanément il aurait pu
déjà transporté oui parce que nous nous
avions pensé qu'il a été arrêté pour
vérifications d'identité et ce n'est que
le lendemain samedi que j'ai été
contacté par la police pour m'informer
qui n'a pas été arrêté par la police
française ma part je crois que le roi
sun dans un discours récent avait
accordé la manne le pardon aux
prisonniers exilés politiques
alors il semblerait quand même que votre
père était parce que amnistié si l'on
peut dire mon frère a été amnistié mai
il attendait à ce que le discours du roi
soit consigné dans un texte de loi pour
regagner le maroc dagen il se préparait
à gagner et vous pensez que quelques
éléments marocain aurait pu interpréter
d'autres façons le discours royal
ceci oui parce que le lendemain du
discours royal le ministre de la justice
a commencé à lui donner une
interprétation qui lui est personnelle
de faire sauf que il y a encore dans les
prisons marocaines des prisonniers
politiques
quant au principal témoin tami hamouri
qui était confronté ce soir avec lopez
il est peu bavard écouter ce qu'il a dit
simplement jouer en simple ainsi vous
avez reconnu monsieur st le monsieur
lebel et je ne peux absolument bien pire
laissez moi tu m'en excuse avait reconnu
qu au ps oui ou non c'est la seule chose
que je demande
les goûter attendait comme en décembre